thing starts with defense and the lakers
are patrolling the pain and
getting out in the early offense and
lebron and
anthony davis showing them what they
came to see here
at staples center
a good pass and finish by anthony
davis and then boom good nurtures as
he's walking down you can't see him
right here but
look at that just just whipping it past
nerf is like my fault
here's the fast break to pass by lebron
and the finish
over giannis here for a.d
and this is a well-designed play out of
the timeout little pick-and-roll action
with
davis at the five diving to the corner
davis
good point
i mean that's right
the jump shooter out top he runs out
lebron into the hands of davis now the
lakers on the run
to lebron lebron all the way freight
train coming look
at the seat of your blazers they don't
they allow a direct
dive to the cup on point pass from
anthony braun james here
he just sees a.d start to get behind he
threw that pass
iron before anthony davis was actually
behind like a quarterback
brandon ingram you got mall it's gonna
give them an extra 14.
to 80. this has been making it happen
lebron the ld or elf look at that
coming downhill well there's the
turnover that leads davis
drops it off and lebron again climbing
he was actually looking for a foul
didn't get it but
[Music]
[Applause]
davis back to james james with a layup
simple they're playing their smaller
guys in the back line
james just seals catches it in the
middle behind the defense here james
plays
behind the defense and then no ball
pressure
here and then full length of the court
passed by lebron to a.d i know he was a
receipt